let's take a cube and dissect it we will
keep this one as the reference take
another cube exactly like this one and
dissect it by dissect I mean that we
will open the cube up along its edges
and what will we get if we open it up
let's see we can open the top face first
this looks like a box with its top face
open then we can open the green face in
the front then we drop the orange and
the blue faces on the right the faces
that remain are the face to the left and
the face behind next we can drop the
left face to the left and then we drop
the only remaining face behind now we
have completely opened up the cube along
its edges to get a two-dimensional shape
like this but what is this what is it
called this is called the net of the
solid in this case it's the net of a
cube a net is a diagram which shows what
the solid will look like when it is
opened along its edges and laid flat the
net as we can see is clearly
two-dimensional if we look at it from
the top it will look like this the
orange face is the face to the right the
blue face is the top face the green face
is the face in the front the black face
is the base the purple one was on the
one at the back and the red one was on
the left yes all we did was open up the
faces along the edges and we got the net
of a solid now listen to the next
question carefully does the net of this
solid have to look exactly like this is
this the only possible net of the cube
maybe not let's see if we can open up
the same cube differently we open up the
top face first along this edge then we
open up the front face outwards towards
the right then we make the side face
fall towards the right there are still
two faces remaining the purple one at
the back and a red one to the left so we
drop the left face towards the left and
a back face backwards this is what we
get it's clearly different from the
earlier one
to know how it's different let's look at
the top view the top view will look like
this so drawing the net of a solid may
result in different figures it doesn't
have to be the same I am sure you have
understood the concept of a net by now
it's easy for me to draw the net of a
three-dimensional shape using software
but how would you draw the net of a
solid in your notebook well you will
have to pull up the hockey Tecton you
look at this cube how would you draw the
net of this cube in your notebook you
don't have 3d software so you need to
imagine one good way to draw a net would
be by naming the faces we can call the
face in the front F and the face at the
back be the face which is down can be
called D and the one at the top can be
called T and L and R for left and right
these are the six faces FB t d l and r
now when we draw the net of this cube we
should make sure that all faces are
covered we should start off by having
one face of the reference let's move
this to the left D would be a good phase
to start off with we draw base B here
now we need to imagine as a fair opening
up the figure we can drop our and T
together towards the right yes we can
drop the face on the right and a face on
the top our would be here and T would be
here next to our we have covers three
faces and all the three remaining faces
are attached to the three remaining
edges of T the face in the front when
dropped will look like this the face on
the left when dropped towards the left
will look like this and the back face
will be attached to the top edge of D
this is one of the ways in which the net
of this cube can be drawn one way to
verify it is by making sure that all the
faces of the three-dimensional shape are
covered in the next session we will look
at nits of a few more figures
you
[Music]